hello grammarians hello paige hi david
so we're talking about possession for
names or words ending in the letter s so
there's some confusion i think about
what to do if you've got to make
someone's name possessive if their name
ends in an s like for example
my friend jess if we're talking about
jess and we're talking about something
that belongs to her like jess's hat
we know that there should be an
apostrophe in there but should there
also be an s the answer is yes there had
been some debate over this for some time
but now let me tell you the answer is
yes jess's hat right it seems like a lot
of s's in a row but it's it's important
for
understanding what someone's trying to
say
so the same the same thing happens um
regardless it can be for words ending in
s uh like bus so if we said you know the
the air conditioning on this bus is
broken we could say instead to make that
a little bit shorter
the buses air conditioning is broken
right and so we're again we're just
taking all of that information about the
air conditioning that belongs to the bus
all of that is just sort of being
bundled up into this apostrophe s
and it doesn't matter that bus already
ends with an s
we're just this this works the same as
any other word we're just going to say
buses if we wanted to talk about the
chile culture of the state of texas for
example we would say texas's chile
culture
yeah so it's exactly the same as any
other singular word even though it ends
in s you still need another s
so just
add
an apostrophe s
and if you didn't know now you know and
that's how to form the possessive for
names or words ending in s you can learn
anything
david out page out